obesity is a condition in which body
weight is more than 20
above normal for age
height and gender
while genetics play an important role in
determining body weight a properly
balanced diet plays an important role in
keeping weight under control and
maintaining body function
the three main nutrients in a balanced
diet are proteins
lipids
and carbohydrates
the recommended daily allowance of
protein for a normal weight adult is 44
to 60 grams or approximately 20 percent
of their caloric intake
protein is needed for growth and
development of muscle and for
maintenance of tissue such as skin
the recommended daily allowance of
lipids for a normal weight adult is 80
to 100 grams or approximately 30 percent
of their caloric intake
lipids have various functions
including energy storage in fat cells
vitamin absorption in the intestines
and composition of cellular structural
components such as the phospholipid
bilayer of the cell membrane
the recommended daily allowance of
carbohydrates for a normal weight adult
is 125
to
175 grams or approximately 50
of their caloric intake
carbohydrates are used by the body
primarily as fuel
they can be simple carbohydrates such as
table sugar or corn syrup or they can be
complex carbohydrates like pasta
vegetables and whole wheat breads
proteins lipids and carbohydrates
compose nearly all dietary calories
lipids are the most energy dense
containing more calories by weight than
either proteins or carbohydrates
when the body has more calories than it
needs to fuel its activities it stores
the excess as fat regardless of the
source
treatment of obesity must be addressed
on an individual patient basis however
some common treatments for obesity
include
diet and exercise
drug therapy such as orlastat which
blocks the absorption of fat
and surgical intervention
such as gastric bypass
and gastric banding
[Music]
you